from a million dollar failure to a
cheating app that broke up with its own
existence these Shark Tank companies got
tons of press and then quietly
disappeared Shelley ehler brought her
business show no towels to the sharks in
season three and was looking for a 50
000 investment and a 25 share in her
business luckily for her things went
better than expected when Lori Grenier
invested 75 000 for the same share
percentage I'm gonna write you a check
right now
[Applause]
and either's luck only seemed to
continue as later that season it was
revealed that grineer struck a deal
between show no towels and Disney which
saw the products sold at Disney water
parks it was almost like a dream come
true except that things quickly fell
through Disney did not reorder ehlers
product which caused a major dry spell
in production for show no towels and
without the house of mouse to back her
up the company closed up shop for a
while however ELO refused to give in to
defeat as she gave her business One More
Try by selling on her Facebook page alas
all good things must come to an end she
announced in August 2020 that she was
throwing in the towel once more and was
pivoting towards a new career path in
November 2021 eeler did pop back onto
the show no towels page to release a few
towels for a limited time and while that
post didn't have too much action there
was one comment that reminisced about
the good old days of her time on Shark
Tank stating that they recognized her
business from the episode and that her
story was touching for their family
Nikki Beau pitched to the sharks in
season 2 and her company toy Guru was a
smart concept Pope described it as being
like a subscription service for
children's toys well parents know the
struggle of constantly buying their kids
toys only for them to get bored quickly
so what are you supposed to do with all
those toys and all that wasted money
well parents could use toy Guru to rent
toys online and then return them when
their child no longer wanted to play
with them my company is the Netflix for
toys
Pope went in asking for a hundred
thousand dollars in exchange for an
equity stake of 10 and while she did
walk away with more than double her
asking price there was some negotiation
to get there Kevin O'Leary matched her
price ask but bumped the equity stake up
to 35 percent while Mark Cuban and
Robert Herjavec did a joint investment
together for two hundred thousand
dollars at a 40 stake however O'Leary
managed to convince Cuban to cut
Herjavec out of the deal by replacing it
with him as he had more experience
dealing with toy retailers Cuban
accepted and Pope took the deal
unfortunately things took a turn
according to toiguru's software designer
and web developer Phil smye in an
interview with Valerie smog claimed that
the team had a difficult time working
with representatives of the sharks in
that the cost of sourcing and shipping
began to spiral out of control
ultimately when there wasn't enough
money to go around the team decided to
shut the company down Neil Desai pitched
an app called Kate in season 4 of Shark
Tank initially Desai had purchased the
app from a police officer that was too
busy to pursue working on it at the time
he paid 17 500 for it but was asking the
Sharks for fifty thousand dollars with a
five percent equity stake Kate was a
privacy app that was designed to hide
calls and messages from select contacts
the side pitched it as being the
ultimate tool to help those attempting
to get away with having Affairs it gives
the user a discreet option and would
therefore help to avoid any potential
fights with their Partners as they'll be
none the wiser about the affair let's
just say if tiger had Kate he might
still be married to Elaine
eventually Desai receives an investment
of seventy thousand dollars for 35
Equity from Kevin O'Leary and Damon John
much to the dismay of Barbara Corcoran
who was visibly disappointed in what the
app represents however Gazette review
reported that the deal fell through
despite this the Shark Tank exposure led
to more than 10 000 people downloading
the app plus Desai was able to persuade
law enforcement and government markets
to give Kate a go unfortunately this
didn't last long and the company has
been offline since 2013. an interesting
thing to note is that Desai stated that
the app would be testing an iOS version
to release but right before it shut down
the app was only available for Android
Sylvie Shapiro and Nicole Brooks brought
their iPad app foot ferry to the show in
season five as a podiatrist Shapiro
noted that most parents simply guessed
their child's foot size and that wearing
the wrong size can lead to major
problems for the children as they grow
older it's because of this that she
invented an easy to use app that allows
parents to track the shoe size of their
child in one easy step at home to
demonstrate this she brought her
daughter out to present to the Sharks by
simply placing her foot on the iPad to
determine her foot size ICE Mark Cuban
offered Shapiro and Brooks an investment
of one hundred thousand dollars for 40
equity and while it looked like a done
deal it unfortunately never went through
after filming according to Gazette
review and it's likely Shapiro and
Brooks really needed this investment to
work as only a few months after the
episode aired foot ferry closed down for
good this is likely due to the fact that
there are now various other shoe sizing
apps to use making the concept seem less
unique plus it certainly wasn't breaking
any Shark Tank records and what's more
well Shapiro had an interesting
connection to the product as a
podiatrist neither She nor Brooks were
app developers so they had to pay an
outside source to do the technical work
season 3 introduced audiences to Megan
Cummins the entrepreneur behind the
company you smell soap a luxury soap
brand then had two different scents wild
pitching Cummins announced that her
company wasn't a pre-venture stage
meaning she hadn't made any sales just
yet however she did send samples out to
stores with a few coming back to her
with interest her pitch was enticing to
say the least a guy can smell the blood
in the water you've got Barbara you've
got Mark circling you can also smell the
lemon too a few of the Sharks offered
Cummins a partnership but it was Robert
Herjavec who sealed the deal as he
offered Cummins an investment of 55 000
with 20 Equity plus the fifty thousand
dollar guaranteed salary in the first
year she graciously accepted this offer
but it was right after that things got a
little strange for Shark Tank success
Cummins was unable to reach her chevec
and his team for six months herzovec
seemed to have forgotten that you smell
soap was a startup and thus had no sales
once he made that Discovery his team got
back to Cummins with a revised offer of
50 of her business it should come as no
surprise that Cummins opted to reject
this new deal however in 2014 Cummins
reportedly sold the brand as the profits
were no longer lucrative
Iowa
season one brought Cactus Jack Behringer
to the sharks with this company body
jack a fitness machine designed to make
push-ups easier for people who struggled
to do them Behringer claimed to be a
lifelong entrepreneur having never
worked a job in his life he went in
asking for 180 000 and 30 equity for
body jack and while he got his dollar
amount investment it was at an equity
percentage of 50. this was also made
with the caveat that he would have to
use the body jack to lose a significant
amount of weight within an allocated
timeline in order to prove that his
product actually worked I'm in for 90
barbers in for 90. we own 50 percent of
the company you have to lose 30 pounds
do we have a deal however things between
Behringer and the Sharks eventually
turned sour especially with Barbara
Corcoran who publicly stated in 2012
that making this deal was a big mistake
on her part body jack officially cut
ties with the sharks in 2013. but
Behringer determined to push on with his
product and he was able to do so for a
few years with his company lasting until
2015 at the latest unfortunately for him
body jack didn't have enough longevity
with the company officially closing its
doors sometime after that year it's
clear that body jack was something
special at least for a little while
season 8 of Shark Tank introduced Doug
Foreman's kitchen utensil for spraying
butter beam he was offered an investment
of five hundred thousand dollars from
Lori Grenier with an equity of 14
unfortunately Grenier was forced to back
out of the deal early as the Better
Business Bureau got involved with beam
it was revealed that foreman did not
have a working prototype when he went on
Shark Tank something that he alluded to
having and if there's one thing you
don't want to do it's mislead a shark by
the time Foreman made it to the due
diligence stage of their deal he still
didn't have a prototype and if that
wasn't enough to make Grenier back out
of their deal the Better Business Bureau
investigated beam's parent company
brevda incorporated after calls about
business management were brought to
their attention now he's getting
complaints instead of bites on his
product
33 different customers reported that
their product shipping was delayed by
several months and once they finally
received their package the products
didn't work once the bureau completed
its investigation the parent company was
forced to issue a statement that they
would make a better product to combat
the faulty one however that didn't last
long as the company apparently went
under in 2019 and as for beam the
website is still up in promoting its
time on Shark Tank however the butter
spray products are indefinitely sold out
and the company's social media Pages
haven't posted since 2019. looks like
this is one Shark Tank deal that was
spread too thin Charles Michael Yim
pitched his Breathometer in season 5 of
Shark Tank the berthometer was a
portable device that connected to an app
on your smartphone and was used to
measure the blood alcohol levels in a
person Kim had such a successful pitch
that he was able to get all of the
Sharks interested in investing resulting
in him getting an investment of 1
million dollars and 30 Equity from all
five sharks this valued yim's company at
3.3 million dollars after his time on
the show Mark Cuban would later call the
Breathometer the worst shark tank
investment he ever made claiming that
yam would often take lavish trips rather
than work two weeks later and he'd be in
Vegas partying you know then be on
nectar island with Richard Branson and
I'd I'd text him like what the are
you doing you're supposed to be working
however Yim claims that Cuban statements
are completely off base arguing that he
never used company money on personal
travel things continued to go badly for
Yim as the Federal Trade Commission
filed a complaint against the
barthometer claiming that it lacked any
scientific evidence to back up their
advertising claims in January 2017 the
company reached a settlement with the
FTC forcing them to provide a refund for
every customer that bought a
Breathometer device
Jeff Stroup pitched his easy to use fire
hose connector to the sharks in season
2. he was offered an investment of 1.25
million dollars but there was a major
catch Mark Cuban wanted 100 Equity Cuban
was willing to give Stroop 7.5 royalty
fees and three years of employment in
exchange which Stroop accepted
unfortunately he would come to regret
his decision in time in a statement
posted to Facebook droop claimed the
deal began to change the moment the
cameras were off stating that Cuban
decided that he no longer wanted to go
through with their agreement for Stroop
he believes that Cuban's ego ultimately
got the better of him arguing that the
shark no longer wanted to front the
money and while Stroup claims to hold no
ill will towards Cuban and Shark Tank he
shared his disappointment that by the
time his episode aired he would not be
able to enjoy the exposure that would
come along with it as his company could
no longer afford to carry on icon's
website is still up but the purchase
link sends visitors to an unavailable
Shopify page
foreign